la tempête n'a pas arrêté lui versé 78 à
montigny le bretonneux ce dimanche 1er
mars
union rugby centre 78 est parvenu à
jouer avec les éléments pour s'imposer
dans un match à sens unique contre melun
combs senart ce camp final 42 à 0 avec
six essais à la clé l'équipe se relance
après sept matches sans victoire les
conditions étaient assez extraordinaire
on a retrouvé enfin la porte parce qu'on
a retrouvé la victoire ça n'avait pas
gagné et on va dire que les conditions
nous obliger à nous resserrer à jouer tu
perds plus solidaire et c'est pas plus
c'était peut-être un mal pour un bien
mais on va les conditions des conditions
de jeu inédite qui ont fait de la casse
chez les adversaires les visiteurs ont
dû déclarer forfait avant la fin du
match après plusieurs blessures
il ya eu plein de problèmes mais l
arbitre qui a eu un problème également
et ensuite l'équipe adverse qui était
pas suffisant pour tard et on la met sur
le score était déjà fait en soi donc ça
ne change pas grand-chose à la logique
du match au classement le rc soit 118
est toujours septième du championnat
avec désormais six victoires engrangées
depuis le début de la saison
prochain match dans cette division
honneur le 8 mars prochain sur le
terrain de paris